how can you expect the country to follow
restrictions now
the government has announced england is
moving into plan b of its winter plan
now is the time for plan b and b plan b
plan b in england
what does that mean
what restrictions will we have
and could we go into another lockdown
good afternoon everybody i want to set
out our plan
for managing kobe this autumn and winter
in september the uk government published
its winter plan it set out a plan a and
a plan b for dealing with covert 19. in
essence we're going to keep going we
will continue to offer testing we'll
continue to urge everyone to be sensible
to be responsible wash your hands
use ventilation
consider wearing a face covering
plan a recommended people keep up daily
testing but it was primarily about
continuing to build on the success of
the vaccine program by ramping up
booster jabs but the arrival of the
omicron variant and rising cases meant
the government has now had to move to
plan b
so what does that involve mandatory face
coverings in certain settings mandatory
vaccine certificates in certain settings
and a request for people to work from
home if they reasonably can do so
the government made it clear that plan b
would only come into effect if the data
suggests the nhs is likely to come under
unsustainable pressure
and up until now the success of the
vaccination program has mostly prevented
the need for further restrictions
but the discovery and arrival of the
omicron variant has changed that
scientists believe omicron spreads at a
much faster rate than any previous
variant of covert 19 and there are fears
it may have some resistance to vaccines
though more data is needed to be
and certain then the health secretary
has confirmed the variant is already
spreading between people in the uk
the omicron variant is continuing to
spread here and around the world this
includes cases with no links to
international travel so we can conclude
that there is now community transmission
across multiple regions of england
the introduction of more coveted
measures combined with revelations about
downing street officials partying when
london was under tier three restrictions
last year have you lied to the public
prime minister could be a painful hit
for the government
omicron restrictions had the potential
to be the most unpopular yet when it
comes to the parliamentary party even if
stammer supports it and you get it
through perhaps on labour support it's
not a comfortable position the prime
minister is going to find himself in
plan b is a long way from a full
lockdown pubs restaurants nightclubs and
shops can all remain open the real
question is will the measures really go
far enough similar measures already in
place in scotland and wales and that
hasn't exactly held back the spread of
omicron this is politically painful for
the prime minister and he'll want to do
everything possible to avoid further
curbs
[Music]